you're of course a scientist who's
studying
humans as a collective i tend to be just
a one-person scientist of just looking
at myself
and you know i play when these deep
thinking
deep work sessions i'm very cognizant
like in the morning
that there's times when my mind is so
like eloquent at being able to jump
around from ideas and hold them all
together
and i i'm almost like i step back from a
third person perspective
and enjoy that whatever that mind is
doing i'm i do not waste those moments
i and i'm very conscious
of uh this like little creature that
woke up
that's only awake for if we're being
honest maybe a couple hours a day
uh early part of the day for you early
part of the day not always well early
part of the day for me is a very
uh fluid concept so you're one of those
yeah i'm one yeah you're one of those
being single one of the problems single
and
no meetings i don't schedule any
meetings
i i will i've been living like a 28-hour
day so
i like i uh it drifts so
it's it's all over the the place but
after
a traditionally defined full night sleep
uh whatever the heck that means i i find
that like in
in those moments there's a clarity of
mind that's just
this everything is effortless and it's
it's the deepest dyes intellectually
that i make
and i i'm cognizant of it
and i try to bring that to the other
parts of the date that don't have it
and treasure them even more in those
moments because they only last like five
or ten minutes
because of course in those moments you
want to do all kinds of stupid stuff
that are completely
is is is worthless like check social
media or something like that
but those are the most precious things
in in
in in intellectual life is those
mental moments of clarity and i wonder
i'm learning how to control them
i think caffeine is somehow involved i'm
not sure exactly sure well because
if you learn how to titrate caffeine and
everyone's slightly different with this
what they need but if you learn to
titrate caffeine with time of day and
the kind of work that you're trying to
do
you can bring that autonomic arousal
state into a
close to perfect place and then you can
tune it in with you know
sometimes people want a little bit of
background music sometimes they want
less these kinds of things
the the early part of the day is
interesting because the one thing that's
not often discussed is the transition
out of sleep
so there's a book um i think it's called
winston churchill's nap
and it's about naps and and the
transition between wake and sleep
as a valuable period um i've
a long time ago um someone who
i respect a lot was mentoring me said um
be very careful
about bringing in someone else's sensory
experience early in the day
so when i wake up i'm very drowsy i
sleep well but i i don't
emerge from that very quickly i need a
lot of caffeine to wake up and
whatnot but there's this concept of
getting the download from sleep
which is you know in sleep you're you
were essentially expunging the things
that you don't need
the stuff that was meaningless from the
previous day but you were also running
variations on these algorithms of
whatever it is you're trying to work out
in life on short
time scales like the previous day and
long time scales like your whole life
and those lateral connections in layer
five
of the neocortex are very robustly
um active and across sensory areas and
and you're running a
an algorithm or a you know a brain it's
a brain state that'll be useless in
waking you wouldn't get anything done
you'd be the person talking yourself in
the hallway or something about something
that no one else can see
but in those states you do
that the theory is that you arrive at
certain solutions and those solutions
will reveal
themselves in the early part of the day
unless you interfere with them
by bringing in social media is a good
example of you
immediately enter somebody else's
space-time sensory
relationship someone is the conductor of
your thoughts in that case
and so many people have written about
this um what i'm saying isn't entirely
new but
but allowing the download to occur in
the early part of the day
and and asking the question am i
more in my head or extern am i in more
of an enteroceptive or exteroceptive
mode
and depending on the kind of work you
need to do if it's it sounds like for
you it's very enteroceptive
in the and very you've got a lot of
thinking going on a lot of computing
going on
allowing yourself to transition out of
that sleep state and arrive with those
solutions from sleep
and plug into the work really deeply and
then
and only then allowing things like music
news social media
doesn't mean you shouldn't talk to loved
ones and see faces and things like that
but some people have taken this to the
extreme
when i was a graduate student at
berkeley there was a guy there as a
professor
brilliant odd but brilliant
who was so fixated on this concept that
he wouldn't look at faces in the early
part of the day
because he just didn't want to anything
else to impact him
now he didn't have the most um rounded
life
i suppose but if you're talking about
cognitive performance this could
actually be very beneficial
you